[Music]
all I want you to do is put the poi in
your left hand and I want you to play
get just get the point moving in any way
possible like you're a five year old kid
with a new toy and you have no idea what
to do with it um but you want to be
something so I just want you to swing
around you can like attack things in
your living room you can chase your pets
you can bounce it off your body off your
legs off your feet
off your head you can try to figure out
what kind of shape you can make you can
think of your favorite superhero and
like they're fighting some super villain
you can throw the poi and then go get it
you couldn't pretend you're stretching
for water like the dowsing rod you can
pretend it's a pet you can pretend it's
a scientific instrument for measuring
things you can let it swing
you cannot swing towards you can get out
of the way Nautica under your legs once
you've learned pull over
you can never go back to playing poi
like you don't know anything again
so you'll never ever be able to do this
again
playing not knowing anything so if
you're totally new to POI
you're in a really fortunate position
and take advantage of it
so whatever it is every time you're
gonna play play take a little bit of
time whatever you've learned let go of
it and just play just be all the new boy
stuff all with some sort of people just
playing if you want to be inventive with
this a little bit um it's always you can
already start so enjoy that and I'll try
to keep reminding you to do that
throughout the course
[Music]